Goomba
Background Ms. Elsa Kanzaki
This is my first ever fan letter
I love Elsa's songs and your singing voice always heals
me.  Since then, I've always had a complex
about it.Even if I wanted to join my circle of friends, I thought that I would be overwhelmed because of my height.
Because
if I become a character that is different from reality, I might be able to solve the problem of interacting with people,
and I was able to become a small and cute character in that vr game
.
The game is called "Former Geron Line" and it's a pretty bloody game where you shoot each other with guns in a devastated earth
, but
even so, while listening to your song, I become a small and cute girl and try to change my real self
even a little.  I
'm sorry for writing such ramblings
Lastly,
I would like to ask Mr. Erdo to perform in a bigger venue if possible.
I think
so please keep making lots of wonderful songs from
your big fan
Kohiruimaki